neither Steve here today was kind of a
slow day as far as Korean is concerned
although I still I'm still gonna get in
an hour or so of reading and linking
creating links on my computer on my iPad
and I had to drive out for a luncheon
meeting was a good half hour there how
far back so that's a good hour of
listening I had lunch with a Chinese
person so he spoke two hours of Chinese
I guess if I knew a Korean person that I
could go out and have lunch with because
I'm at at level now where I could
actually have a conversation and one
person asked in seeing the latest video
or I spoke to Hama in Korean person
asked do you think in Korean or do you
think in English sure and this often
comes up do you think in English to
translate from English into these other
languages and so forth and I have to
admit it's not something that I asked
myself and I never I'm not even aware of
it for example in Korean now because my
Korean is still limited and I think when
I'm weak in a language what I tend to do
is I tend to say things that I can work
around those words that I feel confident
using so I will sort of my language
flows around the words that I know I'm
able to use to some extent I think I am
translating or thinking in English I
don't know it's not a it's not something
that I asked myself and I always wonder
why people ask this question similarly
when I'm working my way through a text
I'm just looking to gain meaning from
this so obviously I look up on link I
look up individual words whether they be
new words or previously saved words
which are now in yellow and I remind
myself of what those words mean but it's
all over the sense of trying to make
meaning of this text that I'm reading
and I'm not aware of whether I'm trying
to translate or not I'm looking for
meaning and similarly when I'm listening
to something that I I either understand
it we're all minutes it's not an issue
of translating or I'm only getting bits
and pieces so then I'm looking
words that I know so that I get a sense
of not only of the meaning but of how
people use those words and I don't know
I just don't think about whether I'm
translating or not translating I'm
always striving for meaning and so if
I'm speaking I can achieve meaning by
using words that I know I can use if I'm
listening I'm looking for words that I
can make meaning out of if I'm reading
I'm doing the same I'm always striving
for meaning whether that meaning is
coming at me somehow directly from the
language or via my language I don't know
and it's not something that I asked
myself so it isn't much of an answer but
because this question comes up all the
time I thought I would address it so
there you have it do I translate from my
own language
do i yeah
do I camera but what the question was do
I oh yes do I think in English first and
then speak in Korean I don't think I
don't think I do I think I go into words
that I can use when I'm at a weaker love
them and when I'm at a stronger level I
think still to some extent we tend to
stay within the limits of those words
that we know we can use and the more
words we have the more with words we can
use okay thank you
bye for now